the banner reads freedom to navalny
putin to prison up for 10 seconds before
the police close in it's brave on red
square right in front of the kremlin
because ahead of parliamentary elections
this weekend the kremlin has waged an
unprecedented crackdown
it started with the poisoning of
opposition leader alexey navalny last
august now he's in jail and nearly all
his top team have fled russia
with apple and google now caving in to
pressure to remove navalny's app from
their app stores because it belongs to
an organization the russian state deems
extremist
and it's not just the opposition it's
the independent media too like dodged or
rain tv recently labelled a foreign
agent
which means laborious audits and this
lengthy disclaimer on every post and
article declaring you an enemy of the
state
what do you think that the kremlin is up
to because
this year and the last few months have
really seen an escalation
i think
for a long time
russian authorities they were pretending
that we have a democracy
here but one day they decided not to
pretend anymore
in moscow at a rain-soaked meeting with
journalists parliamentary candidates
promise they'll fight to repeal the
foreign agent law
irina dalinina is an investigative
journalist for an outlet called i
stories
it's been declared a foreign agent and
so has she
i'm afraid that after election
it will be like a
tsunami
it will be a
catastroph catastrophic yes because i
guess many some journalists will put in
jail if they
won't
[Music]
be able to leave the country earlier
no one here thinks that the pressure on
journalists is going to let up no one
here thinks that the pressure on any
kind of opposition is going to let up
now that navalny has been jailed and his
associates essentially run out of the
country this feels like a
small forlorn little gathering at a
really sad moment for civil society in
russia
even the established opposition parties
generally more token than anything else
are getting whacked
we're at the lenin state farm just
outside moscow the boss here pavel
grudenen was barred from running for
parliament for the communist party he
ran for president against vladimir putin
in 2018 winning just 12 percent of the
vote but enough to rile powerful forces
[Music]
um
forgotten and bankrupt groudinin says
he's faced lawsuits at every corner but
barring popular candidates like him runs
the risk of turning the communist party
into an actual political force
and ratings for the ruling united russia
party are the worst they've ever been
president putin is weirdly nervous about
these elections
these soviet-style repressions a way of
destroying anything that might chip away
at the edifice of power
dynamagne sky news moscow